well we should teach in school in
general is not this kind of spoon
feeding of facts because we carry the
facts around in our pockets what they do
need to learn is a thirst for knowledge
and ability to learn new material to
explore an area with a vision of what
you want to accomplish so
entrepreneurship where you have some
passion for a project and you want to
accomplish something could be a
technology project like a new search
engine like larry page and sergey brin
did or it could be a theatrical project
or an art project music whatever there
are a lot of entrepreneurial initiatives
at the college level we need to bring
that into high schools and junior high
schools well a colleague of mine peter
diamandis who's chairman of the XPrize
foundation and i started a new
university it's a very entrepreneurial
II organized program where the heart of
the program is the students actually
taking on projects where they help to
make a major change in the world in
effect a billion people positively
within ten years they've taken on issues
like solving the water problem or
creating very inexpensive high quality
housing for the third world by creating
basically modules that you can snap
together a house using three-dimensional
printing it's important to have that
exponential perspective I think that
needs to be brought into education